[موسيقى] يقع
قلب إجازة كوست ديل سول
هنا مباشرة
على الشاطئ ،
يذهلني دائمًا الجميع في الشمس يسمرون طوال اليوم بسبب قدوم الناس إلى
هنا لمدة أسبوعين ولا يفعلون شيئًا سوى
الجلوس على الشاطئ أو بجوار المسبح ثم
العودة إلى المنزل  مثل جراد البحر
[الموسيقى
] ، جلب الشاطئ والنبيذ
العلامة التجارية توني هنا منذ 27 عامًا ، أصبح طاهياً
بدلاً من ذلك ، وجد شيئًا أكثر
تغذية ،
أوه ،
هذا رائع ، كيف يصبح
طاهٍ بريطاني متأرجح
أحد الرواد  هواة أكاديميون
، أجنبي يعاني من
صعوبة كبيرة في الفلامنكو ،
أخذني شخص ما إلى
قضيب فلامنكو يختلف عن تابلوه تابلوه وهو عامل جذب سياحي ، في حين أن Penu هو المكان الذي تميل فيه إلى الحصول على
الفلامنكو الأصيل
بمجرد أن بدأ الحذاء كان هناك رجل على
الغيتار
رجل آخر  من اعتقدت في ذلك الوقت أنه
يبكي هذا ما بدا
مثل
[موسيقى]
وكان الإيقاع
قدمي المرأة فقط
وعلى مفاصل أصابع المغني حيث
يعزفون على الطاولة
لم أفهم ذلك ،
لكنني اعتقدت أنه كان
هناك شيء رائع اعتقدت أن هناك الكثير
لهذا أكثر من صيد الحيتان معظم
البريطانيين الذين جاءوا في
السبعينيات والثمانينيات في عطلة ،
لقد كان
عرضًا ليليًا يوم الخميس
في الفندق  الأمر الذي لا
علاقة له بالفلامنكو وقد قال لي
أحدهم يومًا ما كرجل إسباني ، الطريقة
الوحيدة التي ستفهم بها هذا
هو الدخول مع المجتمع الذي
يؤديه بالفعل
[الموسيقى]
توني هو طريقي في
نعم
ولكن قبل أن أخلط قدمًا أو
أنفض معصمًا ،
أريد أن أنظر إلى الجزء ،
أوه ، انظر إلى ذلك ،
لكن في الحقيقة يبدو أنني أذهب
عبر الحديقة ، لا ، هذا سيكون
نموذجيًا لما يسمونه بالإسبانية
يبدو وكأنه قبعة رجل عجوز  لا أريد
أن أكون
متحفظًا ، لكن هل حجم الحافة
يشير إلى أي شيء
لا أعتقد أنه صوديوم ، أين
انتظرت هارلي
دائمًا اربطه علي بشكل طبيعي إلى الجانب
الذي مع عدم وجود
مروحة أحب ذلك  انظر إلى هذا ،
هل أحتاج إلى واحد من هؤلاء ، نعم هذا هو
لك  ساقك الثالثة ، ما هي ساقك الثالثة
هناك ، نذهب ،
هاه
الآن تعال هنا الآن لا لا لا لا
الآن للشيء الحقيقي وقد
قدمني توني إلى سوزانا مانثانو ،
وستسهلني على تعلم الفلامنكو
شيء قضت حياته في الارتقاء به
إلى  شكل الفن الثالث
[موسيقى]
متحمس وغريب ساحر ولا يرحم تمامًا
في سعيها وراء الفلامنكو
[الموسيقى]
، يعد مركز كاليبو فلامنكو للفنون
موطنًا للطلاب من جميع مستويات
القدرة ،
ولحسن الحظ
[تصفيق]
تقول حقًا
إنه من السهل
نسبيًا الحصول على  حذاء لإحداث ضجيج
ولا يمكنك تزييفه
حتى يكون لديك الخبير
بجوارك ، أعني أنني
ولكن لا أحد ينخدع بهذه الرقصة التي
أفعلها في الوقت الحالي هل هو حب هل
هو شغف؟
أنا إخفاق في الفلامنكو
وهنا لا يهم سوزانا هي
حب الحقيقة ذاتها التي أستمتع
بها كثيرًا ، وأنا أشعر
بتجربة سوزانا [الموسيقى] التي جعلتني أشعر
بالرضا للغاية
[موسيقى]
لقد جعل حماسها يصل إلى
duende
[موسيقى
] الثنائي  هل هي مثل الريح
لا يمكنك الشعور بها ولكن
لا يمكنك لمسها ولا يمكنك
رؤيتها وهو شيء
سينقله الراقص حتى عازف الجيتار
إنه المستوى الذي
يصلون إليه أثناء
الأداء وعندما يصلون إلى هذا المستوى
يمكنهم نقل ذلك إلى الجمهور
[تصفيق]
إنه أمر رائع للغاية أنه
بمجرد ظهوره ستعرف مع
الفلامنكو إذا تم ضبطه على
إنهم يقومون بأدائهم ،
يمكنك الشعور بأنه تم
ضبطه عند
تشغيل duende في صباح الخانق الكامل
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
أنت